The tokenizer pipeline. In this video, we'll look
at how a tokenizer converts raw text to numbers
that a Transformer model can make sense of,
like when we execute this code. Here is a quick
overview of what happens inside the tokenizer
object: first the text is split into tokens, which
are words, parts of words, or punctuation symbols.
Then the tokenizer adds potential special tokens
and converts each token to their unique respective
ID as defined by the tokenizer's vocabulary.
As we'll see it doesn't actually happen
in this order, but viewing it like this
is better for understanding what happens.
The first step is to split our input text
into tokens with the tokenize method. To do this,
the tokenizer may first perform some operations
like lowercasing all words, then follow a
set of rules to split the result in small
chunks of text. Most of the Transformers
models use a subword tokenization algorithm,
which means that one given word can be
split in several tokens, like tokenize
here. Look at the "Tokenization algorithms"
videos linked below for more information!
The ## prefix we see in front of ize is
the convention used by BERT to indicate
this token is not the beginning of a word. Other
tokenizers may use different conventions however:
for instance ALBERT tokenizers will add
a long underscore in front of all the
tokens that had a space before them, which is
a convention used by sentencepiece tokenizers.
The second step of the tokenization pipeline
is to map those tokens to their respective IDs
as defined by the vocabulary of the tokenizer.
This is why we need to download a file when we
instantiate a tokenizer with the from_pretrained
method: we have to make sure we use the same
mapping as when the model was pretrained. To do
this, we use the convert_tokens_to_ids method.
You may have noticed that we don't have the
exact same result as in our first slide — or not,
as this looks like a list of random numbers,
in which case allow me to refresh your memory.
We had a number at the beginning
and at the end that are missing,
those are the special tokens. The special tokens
are added by the prepare_for_model method,
which knows the indices of those tokens in the
vocabulary and just adds the proper numbers.
You can look at the special tokens (and more
generally at how the tokenizer has changed
your text) by using the decode method
on the outputs of the tokenizer object.
As for the prefix for beginning of words/part
of words, those special tokens vary depending on
which tokenizer you are using. The BERT tokenizer
uses [CLS] and [SEP] but the roberta tokenizer
uses html-like anchors <s> and </s>. Now that
you know how the tokenizer works, you can forget
all those intermediaries methods and only remember
that you just have to call it on your input texts.
The inputs don't contain the inputs IDs however,
to learn what the attention mask is, check
out the "Batch inputs together" video.
To learn about token type IDs, look at
the "Process pairs of sentences" video.